right now
a deadly officer-involved shooting is
caught on body camera video in Maryland
after an eight-hour standoff
shots fired
yep
they fell backwards into the into the
house
hey bring Watson around grab the bunker
get the uh get the bot over here it
happened on June 4th in Eldersburg
Maryland about 30 miles Northwest of
Baltimore at about nine o'clock that
evening Maryland State Police received a
report of a suicidal man who contacted a
crisis hotline the man later identified
as 52-year-old Jack Cimino Jr was
threatening to commit suicide or
instigate suicide by cop at the time
officials say he was quote under the
influence of an unknown subject
[Applause]
right
body camera video shows the response
from the first troopers on the scene who
confirmed the suspect is threatening
suicide by cop I got lights on in the
bottom one
I got no lights on oh the two floors
though how do we get this address
[Applause]
we'll try some information
um
flag outside
[Applause]
what's his name Jack I don't know if you
heard
I don't know who this cat is
Hey sir
[Applause]
oh he's going inside
I don't think that's him
I went over there there were like 200
people there is that I tried it over
here I tried to clear it out but there
are so many people
yeah it's not gonna work
don't be assholes yeah that's
right
what they say his name was Jack
[Applause]
as officials watch for Cimino's location
they confirmed he hung up on the crisis
hotline after seeing State Police arrive
got movement
Open Door you stand the door
Matt uh it's that house right there
[Applause]
yeah
see if we can get a perimeter on that
side
hey guys
throwing a porch yeah right there you
just signed your light at
[Applause]
he said he was able to see the police
what do you want to do in this situation
uh we're standing we're going to stand
behind the prices intervention
um gets here it's essentially right now
it's a
uh he's inside so it's First Responders
can then be heard discussing a plan
after Cimino announced he was armed with
multiple weapons
he opened the doors landed and that's
about it okay we've got two shotguns
around back
of our CRT guy is coming cool and
another rifle coming from Westminster so
I have a couple long guns here perfect I
appreciate that man
okay
[Applause]
before somebody can talk to him okay he
threatens suicide by cop so he said he's
got nine guns
he doesn't need anybody else down there
the only thing is I don't know if he's
got access to that top floor which is
then
they just like in the bear here yeah I
would say no but it's hard it's hard to
say
if he's got access to one of these
flakes white just turned off on the by
the deck all right
we'll drop back okay guys
so awesome okay thank you sir appreciate
it as the standoff continues officials
can be heard discussing a less lethal
option to slow down cemino if he
approaches with a weapon still want to
do that yeah I think so because if he
comes out that other door over there
I'd rather have an extra couple guys
over there to deal with
there we go
as soon as you guys got that squirt away
can one of you bump around with Roy just
because he's got the 40s that way we
have a lethal and less lethal auction
there
foreign
later First Responders can be heard on
the phone with Cimino working to
convince him to exit the home and
receive help we got through that there
didn't you I mean we walked your way
through that situation and that and I
mean look at where you are outside two
two three success okay
all right
you know can I ask a question then how
do you know
yes
for three or four days
but that doesn't necessarily mean they
just because you go and talk to somebody
at cure high school that they hold you
for 72 hours after Cimino apparently
voices concern about the hospital he
comes outside with a flag in hand
he has an American flag or something his
hands
coming to the door
it's bigger stay
safe
see something that one two window
good luck in the door thanks stupid for
seeing movement over there
that
looks like you might have a flag in his
hand or something later he describes his
time as a volunteer firefighter the
officer on the line can then be heard
reassuring samino that was hours ago you
know that we somebody said that you're
you know we're going to shoot the cops
but I disagree because you threw a nice
flag out here that said you backed the
blue you volunteer with the fire
department I don't know anybody that has
a flag that says back to blue or dead
volunteers
what's that you go what
wait so I don't know anybody that that
backs the blue and there's a volunteer
firefighting and it's going to shoot a
cop
so I yeah like I said I have all the
respect for you jack semino then asks
for a specific volunteer firefighter to
be brought to the scene so it's no way
that I can repay this you know the the
local volunteer hours that you put in
and all the time as a volunteer
firefighter there's no way to go in that
one two bedroom or whatever of you as I
have a good person and future
and we'll take you up to the hospital
myself
oh
you said Eddie wolf you said you'd be
willing to have any any work take you up
to the hospital at you the chief of
Statesville Fire Department
so if I so okay if I if I can make this
happen Jack
would you well we have to we could work
this together if I can get any of you
how will I get you to come out of the
house and trust me that I will get you
the enemy I'm not going to lie to you
and just tell you yeah yeah you know
Eddie's here and he's not and when you
scan the house
if I can get Eddie up here
are you willing to come out of the house
and let me and Eddie take you up to the
hospital
okay
and you're willing to do that so let me
ask you this
come out of the house okay and he gets
here you come out in the house
and they have guns in your hands nothing
like that this fence I appreciate it if
you pick up the phone I just want to
talk can you guys hear that so he's on
his way here
just please pick up the phone and talk
with you I really appreciate it we were
having a good conversations like I said
maybe he's on his way up here okay
I'm not lied to you thank you
we've done nothing wrong there's been no
five to minutes and he's on his way up
here so please
let's pick up the telephone and talk
with
Vinnie where do you want him to go
through Eddie yeah when he gets here
that's up to these guys here
okay that's up to these guys here you
can be escorted up here behind a cat
later samino references the 1998 movie
The Negotiator where actor Samuel L
Jackson and Kevin Spacey play expert
hostage negotiators
why do you feel like Denzel Washington
Chad why do you feel like Denzel in
Washington
oh I I thought that was uh somebody else
in that movie
yeah I think it was Samuel L Jackson and
uh
yeah yeah
it was uh him and I can't remember what
the other guy's name was the uh the
negotiator that Samuel Jackson wanted to
come in and talk
right yeah
so Kevin Spacey that was the other guy's
name
yeah
what why is it uh is that what you think
this is
I said is that what you uh is that what
you think I am is uh Kevin Spacey
excuse me uh with Chris Sabian yeah that
was the character's name
yeah
yeah with it uh we did a Samuel L
Jackson say I didn't want to talk to
Chris Sabian
okay well I have your cressabian on the
way
and that is Eddie the standoff continues
from late evening until the early
morning hours when First Responders
again tried to convince samino to come
outside unarmed
please
[Music]
I'm sorry I'm sitting next to this
engine I can barely hear you
just come to me and we'll talk
[Music]
can you kill the engine for a second
say again
okay
you need to get to a bathroom well why
don't you just take a seat then
right there
all right he's out on the steps we're
talking to
okay
okay awesome can you can you make it
down the stairs you all right
okay
okay okay all right that's fine can you
make it down these stairs at all
okay
[Music]
yes
okay
all right
we can make something happen for you
just just come walk down to us for a
second okay we can take you back into
the bathroom buddy all right we'll get
you back in there I promise all right
can you just come down the steps
no
let's see why'd you talk
wow
that didn't work
during this time officials continue in
an attempt to reassure samino
[Music]
a little better
oh God
Jack step out of course if we can hear
you better we can't help you if we can't
hear you
[Music]
okay
but when Cimino refuses to drop his
weapon officials can be heard discussing
other options
we're here to help you
Jack I think
but give me a chance to understand Jack
Jack
[Music]
also that we can help
nothing is impossible
yeah look at the fox he may have he's
pointing at the pistol right back at us
again right now I don't know how long
we're gonna have to deal with them can't
get hard for me to talk to you because
what's that down
on separate body camera video Cimino can
be heard yelling at officers saying he's
armed with a loaded AR-15
and I got 50. do it
and they're all loaded
you better bring more than that mother
because I'm gonna Flash
okay
when samino allegedly approaches the
door armed again Sergeant Jesse Hartsock
opens fire
that's fire
yep he fell backwards into the into the
house
bring Watson around grab the bunker
get the uh get the bot over here
I don't know after this officials plot
their next steps
right here down that's right inside the
door to the right up okay I saw a lot of
going on
you can't okay
so it looks like he fell in the couch
maybe yep
all right
did he have shoes on though
I don't know
so where's the
yes there's a door so it should be just
in that yeah can they go up to the foot
yeah
you see the gun laying there too
yeah that's that's his feet there okay
yeah okay
[Music]
hey Dave looks like he fell onto the
couch we can see his feet there's blood
on the floor okay and I see that handgun
so I'm I'm comfortable pushing up to
check on Troopers then approached
Cimino's home
I think we can I guess there's no way to
get that door from down you know without
going up on there yeah the pipe hole if
it's open already you could probably
push it open I don't know if it's looks
like it's already open okay let's go up
YouTube post on the left side there on
the hinge side see if you can pop the
door and get a look in with a bunker
okay because that's the direction there
that we need to be looking okay
still got eyes Roy yeah yep
got blood at the door jamb there so
yeah yeah
brother Jack let me see your hands video
from another angle shows other First
Responders securing the scene yeah
you mean you Jacob stand by
oh man
brother
watch your head
officials later determined Cimino had
been shocked he died as a result of his
injuries right now the shooting is still
under investigation and later it will be
up to the Carroll County State's
Attorney's office to determine whether
Hartsock will face charges reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie